[Music]
thank you
blood is a useful substance not just for
our life but for our way of thinking
it's served as a convenient metaphor for
so many ideas covering the extremes and
even the contradictions of our
experiences it signifies life but also
accompanies death it unites those who
share it but in doing so it divides
others it runs hot it runs cold whatever
it is we need to describe blood is there
for us to project onto flowing through
us
and yet under the microscope blood
doesn't seem that remarkable the colors
may be Vivid but the cells are so simple
and similar to one another
how is it that our complicated
contradictory sense of self recorded in
literature and painting and film how
does all that come down to a fluid made
up largely of the simplest cell in our
body a cell so singularly focused on its
task of carrying hemoglobin that it
actively has to get rid of the
organelles and DNA inside of it
but if we track the origin of these
cells we get a more complicated picture
of what they mean to us and to our
bodies and even to our own identity
[Music]
our blood is a soup made up of cells
swimming around in water salts and
proteins there are platelets tiny
fragments of cells that help clot our
blood when a vessel breaks then there
are white blood cells which help protect
our body from infection but the cells
that are most prevalent in our blood are
red blood cells they're pigmented Red by
hemoglobin which helps the cells
transport oxygen to our tissues and
organs and then transports carbon
dioxide back to the lungs the blood
you're seeing now came from James our
master of microscopes who had just been
scratched by his cats so you can see the
red blood cells that came from the wound
along with the white blood cells and to
better see those white blood cells James
added something else to a slide
spit
that spit carried bacteria fresh targets
for the white blood cells
in our bodies white blood cells have a
very specific job they decide what
belongs there and what does not they
seek out molecular markers on bacteria
and other microbes that have become
familiar to our bodies over ages of
evolution there are different types of
white blood cells and they vary in the
types of organisms they look for and how
they deal with them but our favorites
might be the white blood cells that like
the one in the middle of our screen here
consume their target immunity is often
described in more like terms but I like
to think of it as something else
identity in effect the white blood cells
are part of an elaborate mechanism that
decides what is our body and what is not
they shape our identity from within like
a bouncer who decides on the vibe of a
nightclub based on who they let pass
but bouncers occasionally make mistakes
and so do white blood cells the
consequences for white blood cells are
usually more dire especially if they
begin to turn on us and attack our own
bodies leading to autoimmune disorders
their task of deciding what belongs to
us and what doesn't is a precarious one
a task that still requires outside input
as we attempt to shape their responses
with medication or treatment in
comparison the tasks of red blood cells
are much more straightforward they carry
oxygen and carbon dioxide throughout our
body but despite their very different
lives the origins of platelets red blood
cells and white blood cells have a
significant overlap they are all with
the exception of a few white blood cells
made in the bone marrow where they start
as biloid stem cells
foreign
stem cells as young and immature but
what we really mean is that they have
potential the potential to take on one
of a number of identities once they
begin maturing as the cells divide
signals that describe what the body
needs shape what they become if we're
low on oxygen the bone marrow makes red
blood cells if we're sick and makes
white blood cells and these identities
require distinct processes to make them
possible for example to make themselves
capable of holding more oxygen red blood
cells get rid of their nucleus and other
organelles as they mature expelling them
for white blood cells called macrophages
to clear up
consider that a healthy human adult is
producing 2 million red blood cells
every second
now imagine 2 million nuclei being spat
out throughout your body and it falls on
our macrophages to clear them out to
ensure that these bits of us that were
definitely once us now no longer are
that's simplification makes the red
blood cells so capable at their singular
task but what if that wasn't their only
job what if they could do more
well they might scientists recently
reported finding evidence that red blood
cells might work alongside white blood
cells and the rest of our immune system
using receptors to find signs of
infection or tissue damage and to signal
that to the rest of the immune system so
it can act they might even sacrifice
themselves to macrophages to trigger the
alarm this work is relatively new though
and there's still a lot to learn about
the role red blood cells play in
immunity and the more we learn about
blood the more malleable our metaphors
and the more complicated the interplay
between identity and Immunity become but
of course identity is dynamic how can it
not be when it flows through our veins
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the Unseen World
that surrounds us the names on the
screen are patreon patrons these are the
people who have decided to directly
support this channel over at patreon.com
journey to micro so we always want to
take this time at the end of our videos
to thank them for their support if you
want to see more from our master of
microscopes James Weiss you can check
out jam and germs on Instagram and Tick
Tock and you can also find Journey to
the microcosmos on Tick Tock now if you
want some micro micro Cosmos a couple
times a week and if you want to see more
from us here on YouTube there's always a
subscribe button somewhere nearby
thank you
[Music]